[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and after clamoring for
the finale of season five more than
szechuan sauce the double bill is now
here throughout this video we're gonna
be breaking down both episodes 9 and 10
and also going over the easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed now
episode 9 is called forgetting sir rick
marshall which is clearly based on the
film for getting sarah marshall that
movie was about a man getting over a
breakup and this is mirrored in the
entry when we watch rick and morty go
their separate ways the creative team
said they really wanted to ask who was
rick without morty and this episode
explores that theme really really well
now the pair's relationship has always
been pretty strained throughout the
series and this season especially has
seen them going off and doing their own
thing quite a lot this idea of the pair
doing things on their own is hammered
home early on when we see morty
travelling through several dimensions
and fixing the destruction that rick
caused we see him with a full list and
this includes water city spider bot lava
crystal tip jar cookie freedom nuclear
worm return conch bean hordes and moon
gremlin where we start is cookie land
which could be based on the iphone game
of the same name though it's a pretty
generic setting it may also be a nod to
sugar rush speedway from wreck-it ralph
but sometimes yeah
sometimes i just have no idea what i'm
talking about gonna be gonna be
completely honest with you i try to get
the easter eggs but a lot of them are
probably wrong anyway we find out
there's been a military coup and that
the insurgents are about to execute the
president live on tv i'm not touching
this with a 10-foot barge pole as
youtube will slam the yellow icon down
due to the way that the world is but
luckily morty saves the day now from
here he travels to another dimension
with a dam that has a massive hole in it
you might notice that this is the same
shape as rick's ship and morty helps out
before venturing to a beach planet
that's being attacked by a giant lava
monster i feel like this is a nod to
moana as at the end of that movie we
watch as the heroes have to defeat a
giant lava guard called tikar the
inhabitants say that the monster
appeared after its gem went missing and
this is a nod to the heart of tifidi
from the aforementioned film when
arriving back home morty quickly
realizes that rick has started to
suspect this independence as he notices
that the portal fluid tube has been
marked morty quickly tries to cover it
up by mixing in what's left with some
lime juice and it reminds me of when i
was a teen and i took a bottle of vodka
from my parents secret stash drank most
of it because when you're 15 you can
handle it straight for some reason and
came home and then filled it with water
hey presto they never found out or got
drunk again but morty almost gets caught
by the gun detecting weird fluid inside
of it he gets some on his hand and this
unleashes lots of garbage which we learn
as a stash hole for nick's stuff nick
becomes a big character in the episode
and he and morty find some common ground
after he lies about rick ostracizing him
for using his portal gun like morty it's
not the first time i've imagined
someone's face on my hand and from here
we cut to the title sequence now on the
other side of this rick quickly realizes
that something's been tampered with and
he warns him how toxic it is not the
portal fluid the lime juice now this is
really where the divide comes in between
them and morty says that he has to do
stuff like this because rick doesn't
trust him which is definitely true
whenever they go on missions together
he's always the one deciding things and
he says excuse him for not doing the
kissy chef gesture which you should do
on this video rick brings out the wheel
of better things than morty and this is
clearly based on the wheel of fortune
game show amongst the options we can see
a garbage goober half a paul gmarty jean
with donkey brains two crows sentient
[ __ ] bag of meat kyle 2.0 and lastly
jerry and then in brackets spin again
because jerry is clearly not better than
morty now kyle could be a reference to
rick's first sidekick who we heard mr
nimbus talking about in episode 1 of the
season but come the end of 10 that still
remains unknown it lands on two crows
and as the old saying goes if you see
two of them together you'll be blessed
with good luck now we could rick
actually carrying out an experiment with
two crows and this is known as pavlovian
conditioning the original experiments
carried out by pavlov involved releasing
food after a bell was rang and the dog
that he did this on got so used to the
sound meaning a meal that it started to
salivate whenever it heard the noise
this methodology has also been used in
things like whistle training and
basically all manner of getting animals
to act in a certain way the two crows
end up hitting the bell which releases
the food and rick praises them for doing
this he even rewards them by saying the
possibility is there that he might share
some of his bird quaaludes and it shows
the difference between how he treats
them and morty as he'd never give him
anything these crows lead rick on a
journey throughout the two episodes
and it turns him into crow horse a dark
samurai character that ends up
unleashing his murder of crows to murder
people now this breakup slash makeup
motif is often portrayed in sitcoms but
by the end of the episode rick remains
with his two crows whereas morty ends up
alone now speaking of hitting the bell
if you've been enjoying the video so far
then hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and i'll send you a
box of lime juice that definitely isn't
mountain dew we'll have to say that for
legal reasons and we are currently doing
breakdowns every wednesday on what if so
if you're a marvel maniac then this is
the place to be now after having a
conversation with nick morty realizes
that he has someone who's been tossed to
the side like he has on the other hand
hey he could stay in this toxic cycle
with rick but he decides to leave him
and seek snick out this takes him to
harting psychiatric hospital which we
learn is where nick lives he springs him
loose and we get some hilarious dialogue
here where nick says that the gods beat
them on sundays but that's better than
mondays which is where they lick their
faces when they're tied down this is
actually a nodded terminator too namely
when a god licked sarak on his face when
she was pretending to be sedated one of
the gods actually encourages him to run
as he says sweat makes the skin saltier
which yeah very very gross now during
the escape the pair use their combine
portals and a broomstick which they say
is a nod to jackie chan this is riffing
on the film first strike in which he
used one during the most famous fight
scene in the movie nick says that must
make him chris tucker who also starred
alongside chan and rush hour but the guy
got the film wrong and it should have
been morty's first clue that something
was off get rid of him now could to rick
on an indiana jones-esque adventure
through a tomb which contains similar
iconography to the temple in the opening
of raiders of the lost ark there sits a
golden idol above a throne but down one
of the passages we can see little aliens
being crushed and the crows plead with
rick to save them instead of getting the
golden treasure the crows try and teach
him that the true prize is empathy an
idea that he initially rejects and thus
he fires them onto a planet however come
the end of the episode rick does learn
true empathy and he sees that he let
morty down due to the toxicity of their
relationship rick says that if he wanted
another bleeding heart that he'd inject
reanimated serum into an actual bleeding
hot and this is a nod to the zombie
movie re-anime air in which a scientist
found a way to bring corpses and body
parts back to life rick's plan backfires
and he's pulled to the planet where he
comes face to face with the crow leader
later on rick mentions that their place
is very dark crystals meets hot topic
and the design that the crows carry
looks very similar to the aforementioned
puppets by jim henson their ship is
powered by a giant golden one and it
could be reffing on the purple one from
the dark crystal film and series the
leader speaks in what sounds like tongue
twisters and this phrasing could be a
nod of the poem the raven by edgar allan
poe crows and raven species overlap
throughout the world and i know this
because i double checked it on google
now
this might be why he says we train
ourselves to stop training to stop
training the train that are untrained we
are trained all training is complete
nevermore this makes rick realize the
power of the crows and after smoking a a
magic cigarette he realizes he can dunk
on morty even more we then jump back to
morty and see him and nick smashing up
rick's garage aside from jerry doing an
x-men and turning into a giant puddle of
water like senator kelly we can catch
graffiti around there that says portal
boys for life crows suck and crows blow
they get a portal gun and leave in
jerry's car which is when rick returns
home with the crow overlords to find the
destruction left in the wake of the
portal boys the crows aren't impressed
after they find the wheel of better
things than morty and they launched the
crow evolution this idea of birds
turning on humans is similar to the
alfred hitchcock film the birds in which
the animals turned on their masters well
we're not their masters but you know
sometimes we give them bread now there's
an amazing scene in which crows number a
climbing frame and they end up going
wild like what we see in the episode
things are as equally bad for morty as
nick goes crazy and ruins a deal for
portal fluid morty escapes but nick
tracks him down due to them being all
connected and we learn that rick sent
him to the mental hospital after he
tried to steal a portal gun from him on
the train tracks morty cuts off his own
hand and he drops it into nick's leg
which makes him into a singularity that
closes in on itself he heads out to help
rick who is fighting for his life
against the crows however after the two
crows say that they want bird quaaludes
he uses the lightning whips from the
start of the episode to decimate the
lords rick realizes that he has a true
friendship with them and he returns to
morty to give him the bad news during
this he fixes his hand and whilst
listing off the options he mentions the
time that he gave him a giant one which
connects this to the arm of the episode
now rick gives morty the portal gun and
leaves with the crow in a heartbreaking
end
i'm not crying you're right
now the creative team said at the end
that rick being in this partnership with
the crows is what truly opened his eyes
to how he was with morty and it allows
him to move on they said in the end that
it means more when it's an equal
partnership and he ends up going off to
do his own thing with people that are
more his equal as as
they are better than morty to be fair we
do know that for definite now we end
with garbage goober and his wife having
a fallout because she wants him to be
more than rick allows him to be we see
that he's got a degree at harvard
medical school and that he's only
playing this role because rick has
forced him down this path much like he
did with morty he has the chance to
break out of it but unlike our two
characters in the episode he resigns
himself to his fate much to the behest
of his wife he's literally someone
that's put in place to clean up rick's
garbage and it could be mirroring the
start of the episode in which morty had
to go around fixing everything that he'd
broken it sort of foreshadows the arc
that morty also goes on in episode 10
and from here we jump to the rick and to
crows show aka rick moray jack this name
for the entry is obviously based on the
animated show samurai jack which too has
appeared on adult swim we open with
chapter 13 titled a wing and a prayer
which means doing something dangerous in
which you need divine help or luck for
the phrase originates from the second
world war when pilot hugey ashcraft jr
returned home from battle his plane was
badly damaged and didn't look like it
was gonna make it and he then instructed
the crew to pray they returned home and
this story inspired the film the flying
tigers in which john wayne's character
said she's coming in on one wing in a
prayer now we see the owl invasion on an
ancient japanese inspired settlement and
rick arrives much like a samurai to
destroy them morty just so happens to be
in the neighborhood supposedly and we
don't even get to hear what he's been up
to when we cut to an anime and spider
opening we watch his rick roams the land
looking for a man named crow scare and
here he comes across pussifier a
tiger-like warrior that is heavily based
on quintaro from mortal kombat 2. an
older morty arrives to trick rick into
thinking that he's wasted his life but
this is revealed to be a trick and
something similar was used in episode 1
of the season in order to trick morty
the bartender actually calls him a poser
and he correctly guesses that he's not
an old man when he orders a rum and coke
morty recounts how jerry was diagnosed
with stage 4 cancer and that rick would
have loved it which yeah bit of a dark
joke now we learned that in this fake
backstory that summer married a junkie
and just goes to show how much more he
thinks of his sister morty just wants
him to come home but rick refuses and we
occur to him lying in a witcheresque bed
rick is currently pretending to be
asleep and it's at this point he
realizes that the crows are working
behind his back for crow scare though he
was featured in the intro here we come
face to face with him properly and his
design is heavily based on scarecrow a
batman villain from the comics and films
we learned that the crows actually were
his sidekicks originally and that they
used him as a rebound much in the same
way that rick used them to rebound from
morty rick returns home and gives his
crow horse free will which sends it off
on his own adventure to destroy humanity
much like its crow brethren morty just
wants rick to come home and we very much
see that he has no self-respect we
learned that he bought the aging serum
from the citadel and the pair return
there you might remember this from
featuring an episode such as close rick
counters of the rick kind the rickshank
redemption and tales from the citadel in
which we learned that evil morty had won
an election there we see the outcome of
this play out in the episode and
throughout the different versions of the
character including jesus morty lizard
morty and an underdweller morty escaping
from the sewers at the end of the
episode it's revealed that these live
under the citadel and this moment very
much teases towards what's coming down
the line i think the process here is
hilarious and they break every bone in
his body shrink him down to a child and
then push them together he comes out
looking pink like a newborn baby mouse
and we see that the 26 years taken from
him must either be paid for to be
disposed of or taken with them this
creates an adult morty complete with the
same tattoo that he had at 40 showing
that he got it in his younger years much
like how i got my tattoos and magaloff
like some [ __ ] now he's a bloody sjw
and he ends up getting shot after
attempting to save the underdweller who
exposes the truth behind president morty
the president then invites them for
dinner and this is where everything
kicks off it's a very no mr bond i
expect you to dine moment and shout out
tvtropes.org for pointing out that rick
isn't surprised by the reveal as it's
clear he already figured it out way
ahead of time this conversation is very
meta and they talk about how keeping the
show episodic instead of serialized
makes it drama-free it's something that
the fans have debated a lot about this
season and i'm in the camper wishing
that everything kinda had a through line
as i find these two episodes way better
than the majority of season 5. evil
morty very much shows morty that any
morty can be great all he has to do is
ditch rick but as we've seen he's
refused to do this time and time again
we learn that evil morty has a copy of
rick's memories and we see some of these
moments including him building his ship
throwing a paper ball at jerry's head
and also snuffles who you might remember
from the episode lawnmower dog from here
we get an awesome stanley s cameo in
which he pops in to say that the memory
scanning happened in season 1 episode 9.
now i don't know if this is a continuity
error but season 1 episode 9 was
actually something wicked comes this way
whereas evil rick appeared in the
following episode kinda ruined the whole
thing for me and i'm furious but it is
possible that the first episode was
actually a pilot and therefore counted
as zero which would mean that the
following one was episode nine i don't
know yet ask netflix but if you want to
see the continuation of this then you
need to watch season 1 episode 10. see
you kids your uncle kevin spoilers he
never lets you down now we learned that
the citadel is very much a morty market
which explains the builder morty from
earlier we see firsthand how rick's
travel the multiverse making sure that
jerry and beth get together and from
here they then steal his genetic
material and clone him it's an amazing
scene that shows his entire existence is
basically just a cattle market and also
a slaughterhouse before explaining
everything rick escapes using a
screwdriver and his finger and he calls
himself inspector gadget this was an 80s
cartoon that featured a character who
had all kinds of gadgets built into him
realizing that i have to explain that
makes me see how old i am and i just
want to be young again see kids just
don't turn dirty like your uncle kevin's
spoilers and you'll be okay now he let
rick go but it turns out it's a trap and
that evil morty has hacked his portal
gun he ends up creating a clone blob
that likes pain and absorbs it from him
this metaphor for capitalism just gets
screwed over all the time but he enjoys
it much like morty although they escape
evil morty launches his plan and he
hacks the whole city's portal supply you
also see a morty wearing a mask and it
makes me think that he's had to deal
with the pandemic which is definitely
the worst morty timeline possible rick
says that he wants to return to the
single story episodes but at this point
there's no going back and we finally
learned his backstory now in the
rickshank redemption rick said he made
this up to trick the federation when
they invaded his memory he lied and said
all the details were totally fabricated
and that he made it up in order to
control them but we learn here that
other than a few details that it was
true on the most part
this rick stein and beth were murdered
by a version of himself from the
multiverse and thus he set out on a
quest for revenge we see flashes of his
life and prior episodes in this season
including the battle of blood ridge with
bird person which we saw play out in
ricternal friendship of the spotless
mort there's lots of similarities to the
terminator including not only the score
but also rick hunting down specific
characters through time much like the
machine from the movie he is unable to
find peace doing this and eventually he
comes across a version of beth that
wasn't killed which is where he settles
we see all the infinite universes have
been separated and get confirmation that
the one from episode 1 was a different
version of rick and morty when we see
them in the crystals even more he says
that eventually all morty's become him
and he dons the eye patch that he's
classically had morty comes to the
conclusion that rick only returned
because the crows dumped him and not
because he wanted to evil morty
unleashes his plan to destroy everything
and though some believe they're escaping
death by killing themselves all the
souls are rerouted into the factory in
order to power the weapon although it
was so good how evil morty asked morty
to come with him but the second seat was
actually a toilet made you realize how
much like rick evil morty actually was
and the citadel is finally destroyed
once and for all as it collapses into a
black hole now i might be reaching here
but i thought that this ship looked a
lot like chronopolis from marvel comics
the council of ricks was based on the
council of kangs and kang ruled over
chronopolis so that just makes the most
sense to me evil morty travels through a
black hole and we hear his theme once
more but here it's far more grander and
epic he has a golden portal gun and
after confirming the multiverse of rick
is destroyed he travels through it the
creative team said this was very
symbolic of someone breaking free of the
capitalist society that he'd been bred
to be a part of and rick and morty
themselves realized that in working
together they are truly able to live
anew
in the post-credits scene we cut to mr
poopy butthole saying that he didn't get
his job back after the heist episode
after this he cut himself off from his
wife amy and he's very much become the
bad version of himself much like morty
he becomes somewhat of a tragic
character who wants us not to take the
ones we love for granted and this is
very much reflected in rick and morty at
the end of the entry
overall it's a brilliant way to send the
season off and in my opinion this is the
best one out of the ten i had a real
blast with it and i'm gonna talk about
my thoughts on the season as a whole in
just a bit but first i'm gonna see if
youtube will hit you with an advert
because i need to make some money
okay so as for my thoughts on season
five as a whole i kind of think that
there's been a lot of highs but also a
lot of lows looking back this will
probably be a season that skips some
episodes for when doing re-watches and
because of this it's kind of hard to
gauge how i feel about everything
altogether that being said the episodes
i've enjoyed i've really enjoyed and
there have been some standouts here that
i think work really well going forward i
think that the series should just
embrace its canon and have more episodes
involving the characters and plot lines
that have come before there are still
some which have question marks over them
and i think that in the future seasons
that the creators should just focus less
on standalone episodes with potential
versions of the family and just have the
main ones in the picture overall though
i had fun with the season i was also
slightly disappointed in some bits and
hopefully the next one is a lot better
than this just my opinion of course but
i'd love to hear yours so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
september and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the season
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of what if episode 4 which
will be linked on screen right now it's
one of the most emotional things in the
mcu i've ever seen and it's also got
some really cool easter eggs that we
talked about in that video if not then
thank you for saying to this one i've
been paul let's see you next time take
care peace